Crisis on Infinite Earths was a monumental
achievement, and a lot of fun, but it would've
been even better if a couple more DC characters
had showed up to play.
In the end, we plain missed these folks, and
if you're a DC super-fan, you probably did
too.
Felicity Smoak wasn't supposed to be a major
player in the Arrowverse.
Emily Bett Rickards' character was originally
conceived as a one-off guest appearance, designed
to pop up in a single episode and nothing
more.
"Look, I don't wanna get in the middle of
some Shakespearean family drama thing."
"What?"
History had other plans.
Rickards' winning performance, as well as
her undeniable chemistry with Arrow star Stephen
Amell, quickly convinced Arrow's producers
to bring Felicity back for more.
It took less than a season for Felicity to
become part of Arrow's regular cast.
By season two, she was Arrow's heart and soul,
and ultimately ended up as both Oliver Queen's
wife and the mother of his children.
That's why it's so weird that Felicity sat
out Crisis entirely.
Sure, Rickards left Arrow after season seven,
but she's returning for the series finale.
She couldn't pop by for a quick cameo in the
big crossover event, too?
The Crisis wasn't just the biggest threat
the Arrowverse has ever faced, it was also
an epic sendoff for Oliver Queen.
As such, it just felt strange that Felicity
wasn't there to say goodbye.
In the comics, Crisis on Infinite Earths was
Wally West's time to shine.
In Crisis on Infinite Earths #8, Barry Allen,
Wally's mentor, sacrificed himself to destroy
the Anti-Monitor's powerful antimatter gun,
saving the remaining universes from destruction.
Once the Anti-Monitor's plans are foiled,
Wally West sheds the name Kid Flash and takes
over for Barry.
Wally was more than a sidekick.
He was the DC Universe's main Flash for almost
25 years.
Of course, on television, neither Barry nor
Flash star Grant Gustin are going anywhere.
In the speedster ranks, Kid Flash still plays
second fiddle.
Even so, it would've been nice to see Kid
Flash make an appearance in the CW's big crossover.
Wally has been a regular fixture in the Arrowverse
since 2015, when actor Keiynan Lonsdale stepped
into the role, and while we haven't seen much
of Kid Flash since Legends of Tomorrow's season
three finale, Kid Flash is already scheduled
to return to The Flash after Crisis.
Given everything that went down during the
event, Barry really could've used his help
here, too.
Of course, if you really want to see what
Wally and Felicity were up to during Crisis
on Infinite Earths, you can always check out
DC's spinoff comic, which was co-written by
Crisis creator Marv Wolfman.
That's not the same as seeing the characters
on screen, though.
Their absence stood out like a sore thumb.
Crisis on Infinite Earths had a Batman.
It had three different Supermen.
Where the heck was Wonder Woman?
The third and final member of DC's trinity
isn't just one of the best-known superheroes
on the planet.
The Amazonian warrior was the star of her
very own television show, which debuted in
1975 and starred actress and singer Lynda
Carter.
In fact, Carter already has a role in the
Arrowverse.
In Supergirl, she plays Olivia Marsdin, a
shape-shifting alien who, at one point, was
also the president of the United States.
"Remind the world that there is still goodness
here.
Be that beacon of hope that we still need."
Carter appeared in five episodes of Supergirl,
and we're going to assume that executive producer
Greg Berlanti and the rest of the Crisis team
still have her phone number.
Maybe Warner Bros. didn't want Crisis on Infinite
Earths to steal any thunder from Wonder Woman
1984.
Still, a cameo wouldn't have meant that Carter
needed to suit up.
An older, retired Diana Prince would've fit
in well with Kevin Conroy's grizzled, jaded
Bruce Wayne and Brandon Routh's greying Man
of Steel.
What a missed opportunity.
The CW's mega-crossover featured characters
from almost every major television show based
on a DC comic.
Birds of Prey?
Batman '66?
The '90s version of The Flash?
They're all there.
Heck, even Lucifer, which is only tangentially
related to the DC Universe, got a brief but
memorable nod.
But the key word there is "almost."
Lois and Clark: The New Adventures of Superman,
the hit '90s show that re-imagined the relationship
between Lois Lane and Superman as a Moonlighting-style
romantic comedy, didn't get a single nod.
No cameo.
No offhand mention or super-obscure Easter
egg.
Heck, even Super Friends got a nod in Crisis
on Infinite Earths, but Lois and Clark, a
legitimate ratings hit?
Nothin'.
Even stranger, both Lois and Clark's stars
have established relationships with the Arrowverse.
Dean Cain, who played Superman on Lois and
Clark, has a recurring role on Supergirl as
Kara Danvers' adopted father.
Teri Hatcher played the Daxamite queen Rhea,
Supergirl's second season big bad.
Both actors are clearly open to appearing
on the CW.
They've done it before.
Just, oddly, not this time.
The Joker plays a minor role in Crisis on
Infinite Earths, but you'd be forgiven for
not noticing.
He doesn't appear on screen.
Nobody ever says his name.
Still, he's there.
When our heroes visit Earth-96 to recruit
Brandon Routh's Man of Tomorrow, the alternate-universe
Superman mentions that a "reject from Gotham"
gassed the Daily Planet, killing 48 people.
That's a direct reference to Mark Waid and
Alex Ross' graphic novel Kingdom Come, on
which Superman-96 is based.
In that story, the Joker attacks the Daily
Planet and murders Lois Lane, Jimmy Olsen,
and a bunch of Superman's other friends.
That begins a chain of events that concludes
with Superman hanging up his cape and retiring,
leaving the fate of the world in the hands
of a new generation of heroes.
Routh's Superman has the same tragic backstory,
he even sports the black-and-red insignia
that the Kingdom Come Superman wears when
he comes out of hiding, but it would've been
even more powerful if Crisis had been able
to actually show the Clown Prince of Crime.
"You wanna know why I use a knife?
Guns are too quick.
You can't savor all the little emotions."
Maybe Warner Bros. didn't want to distract
from Joaquin Phoenix's award-winning turn
as the character.
Maybe the Arrowverse has plans for Joker down
the line.
Who knows?
Still, something, even if it was just Batman:
The Animated Series actor Mark Hamill performing
the Joker's signature laugh offscreen, would've
gone a long way.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.